well i think i will get going
um let me start by saying uh good
afternoon to everybody and thank you for
attending my talk my name is jerry
thomas
i'm from milwaukee school of engineering
i've been an adjunct professor there for
about
15 years and
currently teaching online like everybody
is so this online experience
getting wouldn't say old hat but it's uh
it's
certainly becoming familiar
so what i'm going to do is
let me start my what i'm going to talk
to you today
about is uh based on work that i've been
doing
uh for a number of years um
it's based on an observation that the
game theory of uh von neumann and
morgenstern
um is equivalent to a field theory of
games
and based upon looking at
game theory as a field theory um
i've been looking at uh the geometry
that results from that theory and the
equations that result from that theory
and uh those equations provide a way of
describing
uh the time sequence by which uh
individuals or groups of individuals
make decisions and how those decisions
might change over time
and that process of making decisions and
the
changes that are made in those decisions
looks very much like a theory of fluids
uh and the behavior in fluids looks very
much like the
fluids that you would get in the navier
stokes equation
i won't kill you with the the math
but if i actually were to write it down
in
in a geometric notation
i would have an einstein type theory
but not in three plus one dimensions but
in general in
n plus one dimensions and i would have
equations that would tell me the
rate at which things flow this would be
the rate of change
v would which would be a flow it would
depend upon
some stresses in red
and and the equations would have some
geometric constructs covariant
derivatives might have
uh coriolis forces for example uh
and specifically in game theory the
coriolis forces are very very important
because those
directly relate to the game matrix from
neumann's theory
so uh in trying to understand those
solutions
for game theory there were a number of
challenges
and um the first
non-trivial challenge is that the
equations that result are non-linear
partial differential equations
so um originally i wanted to use nd
solve for those equations and it was
very tough but with
since release 12 i guess we can solve
pdes with that are non-linear and that
makes my life a lot easier
i can apply it directly
the next challenge is that even for very
simple processes
of two people playing a game each with
two strategies
and we look at steady state so we can
take uh
what time out as a let time
remove time as a variable uh
the partial differential equations are
in five dimensions
an even simpler game you might think
which is tic-tac-toe
has 13 dimensions another problem
a challenge with uh the game
field theory of games is the compression
terms
the fluid is not uh the fluid may be
compressible
okay so the compression terms are not
zero and uh
you might think uh this would be hard to
do such things
is compute streamlines um
there are a couple of solutions to that
one of course one is simply you assume
the compression terms are zero
and can go ahead and compute the
streamlines
another another challenge of course is
assuming that we were very strong we can
get exact solutions to our partial
differential equations in any number of
dimensions we like
there's a challenge of visualizing what
those solutions mean
so the way
we've attacked it so far is to look at
streamlines
ignore the compression terms um
and look at streamlines either in one
dimension
and also generalize the idea of
streamlines to
two dimensional streamlines this gives
us a little bit more
insight into the geometry
what we'll do today is i'd like
in looking at the solutions that i've
done so far
my concerns are uh
particularly with the compression terms
and not getting
accurate results and not understanding
whether those uh to what extent those
compression terms
that have been ignored change the
qualitative nature of the solutions
so a way to study that is to go back to
a problem
that we can compute directly exactly
which is a three-dimensional problem and
so what i'm going to do today is talk to
you about
a three-dimensional navier-stokes
problem slightly changed to make sure
that it has
some aspects of the game theory solution
i'm interested in
but otherwise is a perfectly legitimate
uh
navier stokes problem so here's what it
would look like
so uh the equations
would look like on the left these are
the flow equations that you would
normally have
um a flow vector times a gradient
in x direction in y direction z
direction
and it would depend upon the great it
would be equal to the gradient
of pressure possibly the gradient of a
gravitational field
and uh a convection term that would be
related to the coriolis force all of
these are certainly possible
um things to have in our
uh three-dimensional space one of the
modifications from
game theory that i want to impose is
allow
additional a different coefficient for
say
uh two of the directions say x and y
which i will call player one
and in the z direction which i'll call
player two
uh whether they have any real meaning in
physical uh fluid i'm not sure but the
reason
the purpose of this study is more
mathematical than to try to
create a physical fluid with these
attributes
i need to take some make some
assumptions about
the values of the payoff which i just
take nominally
the values i'll add some gravitational
field i'll add some
stress by one
and
provide a boundary condition okay now
the key for the boundary condition
will be in general i could pick
the flows along the boundary these are
dirichlet conditions
and i can pick these uh flows to be zero
or to mimic some of the things that we
might see in a
field theory of games i've assumed that
the flow
say in the x and y direction are are
are as stated something along the x
direction something along the z
direction
the gradient for player one
i e the gradient along x plus the
gradient along
y is a certain value along z
is negative of that value so i'm going
to assume
on the boundary that the normal
compression term is zero
i could have taken these all of these
terms to be zero for example
um and get
of course different slightly different
solutions but some of the qualitative
features that we're going to talk about
are don't appear to be dependent upon
these things
i should say if i were to take all of
the terms to be zero
as an example all the flows along the
boundary to be zero
all of the stresses in the gravitational
fields to be zero
my flows in the end should be zero which
they are
if i start adding back some stresses
they essentially pull stuff off the
boundary even if the flows were zero
so i generate compression inside the
boundary so that's one of the things we
hope to see
in looking at the solutions
so we're going to use these boundary
conditions and the modified stokes
equations that i showed you above
and we're going to solve uh
things with nd solve i'm really very
happy now that nd soft
is is truly simple all i have to do is
say indie solve and all those
complicated equations go away
um i've not tried it
in n dimensions uh with a full
n-dimensional solution but i have tried
it with
uh n-dimensional problem solutions for
the game theory
of for streamlines one-dimensional and
two-dimensional streamlines and
uh even though the number of variables
is very
very large and these solve seems to be
working appropriately just as a sidebar
i should probably
point out that uh in solving md solve
there are different ways to do it
what i am using is the finite element
uh approach and so what i i have assumed
a certain mesh size
and i've kind of maxed out the mesh size
for my laptop so if this thing
bombs on me i may not be able to
reproduce my curves because it takes a
while to rebuild
so let's look at the solutions
and i should preface before looking at
the solutions is that the goal here
is one take a model find the exact
solutions
and then ask the question based on the
exact solutions how well do those
solutions compare
with the qualitative nature that i might
get from
a streamline a streamline approach
so what i will have to do when i come to
the streamlines
is re-emphasize that streamlines
in general i can't compute
the normal way but streamlines in fact
are simply the integral curves
of a vector field in the geometry so
once i have
the the vector fields computed i can
always compute the integral curves so
that's what we're going to do
so the first thing i have to do is show
you that yes
we can in fact um
well of course we can solve the
equations but we can look at the
solutions that we get from the equations
and for example here are the
flow equations for along x along y and
along z
uh plotted against x and y and you can
see that they have some
a structure which reflects two things
what
in part the boundary conditions so i had
some boundary condition here
and that gets reflected inside even if i
get rid of that boundary condition
however
i will get a structure inside be given
the nature of the
stresses or gravitational fields that i
might impose
so here are the gradients for the player
one the x and the y gradient
or compression if you like here's the z
compression and note that inside the
uh inside our boundary we
generate a fairly strong uh compression
inside so
our on our scale uh if i took everything
away i would hope that this thing is
zero
and you know i get i have a fairly
strong
compression here
i could compute some other things that
might be of interest
in the three-dimensional world that can
compute say the
uh
a velocity for example um
as a density plot
this would be say the the velocity
in point three zero so
it hit it's uh it's zero in the middle
and then he has two sort of lobes on the
edge where it
shows not particularly interested in
that right now
i'm interested in the streamlines but i
do
you know just to show that yes you can
go through and compute lots of
of things about the way the fluids the
fluid looks in this
in this three-dimensional model
lots of lots of kind of cool things you
can do
so here's what i'm looking for okay i
want to compute the streamlines and as i
pointed out
the streamlines are
in in an exact theory what i want to
look at are the integral curves i want
to look at
a curve that moves along the velocity
flow the velocity vector
so i given a solution i need to sort
to create yet another differential
equation
which gives me the fluid flow and then
compute those
so this is the
fluid flow the
behavior of the velocity along x or
along y or along z for the different
colors blue red
green and they oscillate
so i can see blue goes up and then it
goes down goes up because it just is an
oscillatory function
has uh some uh ragged structure which i
suspect
is more to do with the mesh size than
reality
but i do think but some of the structure
is really you know obviously this big
pike is probably irrelevant but some of
the structure
is the curve just oscillatory curve
um if i were to take a very simple
approximation to streamlines i would
have said
that the rate of change of the flow
would be
proportional to uh
the coriolis force times the flow so you
know
sort of v dot equals f dot v so
that's a simple problem to solve and it
has harmonic solutions
and the harmonic solutions would be
based upon the eigenvalues
of the anti-symmetric matrix f and
so we recover that qualitative behavior
in the exact solution we shouldn't be
surprised
which means i don't have to throw away
all the stuff that i did before
but nevertheless i am uh um
happy that i i see that type of behavior
but i also see some additional structure
that i would not have seen
um in my original two-dimensional
uh one-dimensional streamlines so here
are the positions
the actual streamline is a function of
position
and it averages out a lot of the the
numerical noise and i do see
maybe this slight thing here
is a twist but i do see a nice
oscillatory behavior
for red for green and i see some
structure in blue that
repeats itself so i see some additional
structure which results from
looking at the exact solution that i
wouldn't have seen before
if i look at the 3d plot
i start to see also some evidence
i start i have some transient behavior
so if you
are familiar with doing behavior steady
state behavior
in things like circuits in in
electrical circuits in electrical
engineering
it's not uncommon that you start
someplace and you're not near a stable
behavior
a stable cycle and so you start
wandering around and hit the stable
cycle and then now you're
you go around that stable cycle forever
uh see the same thing if i plot it as a
function of
let's say the sum of of the distance in
x
x plus y versus z this is my player one
in the game theory this is my player two
here i start off far away from things
i hit my my uh cycle and i
now you start going around and i now hit
a kind of a steady state
steady state cycle um what does that
look like it
for those of you that are electrical
engineering people
it means that you started a circuit like
an ac
circuit and uh all of a sudden it now
has harmonic behavior and you
you're now looking at the harmonics of
the system um
you've changed from a system that was
very simple
to a system that's a little bit more
complicated you've added more resistors
to capacitors but now all of a sudden
you still see the same harmonic behavior
with a little structure
in in the way in which it goes around
its stable curve
i can look at some other things but i
want to move
on a little bit and say how would i go
and get more
insight into the behavior
in this case the three-dimensional
behavior by looking at a plot
that would be instead of a
one-dimensional um
uh streamline which gives me a
two-dimensional plot what if i could
look at
multiple streamlines okay which would
give me
a two-dimensional streamline slice into
what's going on
that two-dimensional slice that i could
then look at as a three-dimensional plot
so here would be my two streamlines
i have one stream line associated with
variables x and y
and another streamline that's associated
with z
uh as in a sidebar if i'm doing game
theory
uh player one might have ten such
uh choices x bump up
up up to x10 and player 2 might have 20
such choices
z1 z2 z20
i would still have a two dimensional
plot that i could
do in terms of s1 and s2 and
this is these curves you can do in fact
we have done in fact for game theory to
produce
um our two-dimensional slices
getting three dimensional plots so we do
that now for this
case
now solve two two equations more
differential equations
these are two dimensional integral
curves if you like um
so there's no uh they're exact we're not
assuming anything about the
compressibility
and we compute
what i i call these effort streams let's
say a little too far
i get something into as a
two-dimensional plot
for um
green is along the stream line that's a
constant s1 minus s2
so a constant streamline here's my two
dimensional
cycle and i said i can look look at that
in three dimensions so let's look at
that plot
in three dimensions
so i have r1 which is
x plus y i have r2 which is z this is my
sort of quote player one
this is my quote player two it shows me
not just the um
cyclic behavior of the structure but it
starts to show me
uh how the structure can bend and move
in on itself i really start to get a
feeling for
uh the particular behavior of
this fluid
and
just for for ducks if i just compare
that to something that
was computed for a game theory
calculation
um in
i think this was like a a model that had
uh this was a five-dimensional model
and it has a very similar structure
um to the one we just did here
so what have we learned okay um
in using
uh two-dimensional streamlines
we get a picture we get a
three-dimensional visualization
the navier-stokes solutions that we just
did
show us that qualitative nature is very
similar
um
how do we do how do we uh
how shall i say it how do we what do we
really
conclude from this okay we certainly
conclude that we uh we replicated the
kinds of behaviors that that
we saw before in game theory you haven't
seen it but i i've seen
similar behaviors and i showed you one
example
and uh so qualitatively the results
agree
um
what would i like to do so uh i thought
about this for a while and i said okay
if i wanted to take the game theory
calculations to the next level of
computability and uh provide a way
a set of notebooks that i could give to
non-experts people that are not experts
in partial differential equations not
experts in game theory but i give them a
notebook
and i want to give them a reliable way
to see the structure of a game
then i need a more reliable way to
compute the one-dimensional and
two-dimensional streamlines
um i think what i've learned is that the
usual technique that i've
been doing so far is not bad but it
would be much better
and so this is my request it would be
much better if i could get a good
numerical solution
in n dimensions just like i did here in
three
and uh then i could use those solutions
to produce the streamlines and i would
have a much more accurate
uh representation of what's going on in
the game
my understanding and i may be incorrect
is that
right now my ability to do non-linear
partial differential equations is
somewhat limited to three dimensions
so i guess i'm pushing that we could get
move the
geometry and technology
to higher dimensions or possibly is
there a way to
in a slightly different way perhaps
directly get the one in 1d and 2d
streamlines that i want to calculate
without solving the full problem so i
think this is
a place that i would like to
stop and see if i have
um any questions and i and before i take
questions let me just thank you for
uh um your attention in for
attending the talk
professor thomas that does appear to be
a question in the partable chat
okay um could you read it for me
and i will answer it certainly it says
do you use
these results in both decision theory
and fluid dynamics classes
um good question
what i have done um in
i taught a course to software engineers
and software engineers computer
engineers that had no background in
mathematica
and no background in game theory or
geometry or
for that matter much
of differential equations calculus in
general
it was a 10 week course and i started
using
wolfram's little book on mathematica
and based on that book they learned
enough mathematica
i gave them notebooks that allowed them
over time over the course of the 10
weeks to
take the 1d and 2-dimensional
1d and 2d streamlines
and compute the results the result that
i showed at the very end
is the kind of results that they could
do themselves
and they were able to do it and they
were able to analyze it in fact
by the end of the quarter they were able
to come up with their own projects in
game theory and start talking
um about
what those results meant based upon the
the analysis of the curves that they got
out of it
so i hope that addresses if you have uh
want to talk to me offline i would be
more than happy to talk at great length
about that
there are some additional comments in
the departable chat oh we just got one
more question that says what does
zero compression mean in decision theory
um
that's a i'm not exactly sure which is
why in decision theory it's not an
assumption that that i would normally
want to make
um
compression in in a fluid
general has to do with the uh
if if you like the the the forces that
that
that that interact okay if i have
something that that
is zero compression it means things
don't like to come together and they're
they they form like a a rigid body
um i don't know enough yet
or have any intuition or insight yet
as to how that would truly apply to
decisions so right now
for me the compression is something that
i uh
i don't look at as as a given assumption
what i do know however is the flows
um have have a very specific meaning
because
this has to do with the rate at which
people make decisions
along a particular strategy how often
they pick one strategy versus another
that i can set up as part of the
boundary conditions if you like
in the model i was talking about that's
like i can specify the v
x the b y and b z that makes perfect
sense
another thing that is that makes perfect
sense in decisions
would be the stresses the the the phi 1
the phi 2 that i put up there
these are stresses that you can relate
to to actual decision processes
uh people that are under high stress
like in a business
a high stress would actually correspond
to a high value
associated with certain making certain
kinds of choices
this is a something i could parameterize
um clearly and so i can specify those
things
i can also specify with with uh
some sense that there might be some
general attraction that's like the
gravitational field these are
are generalized in in n dimensions
um in in kind of interesting ways
the uh
gravity which we think of in in three
space
uh in in a general space um
comes about because you make an
assumption about
uh an isometry which means a symmetry of
the metric that you use to describe the
situation
the metric in the game theory is related
to the values
that people assign to certain decisions
and it's easy to imagine that certain um
strategies
choices leave the uh
utility in unchanged for example i may
have some
internal choices that i make about how
how my head works
and these internal choices aren't
visible to the outside world
these would be isometries in this theory
of
decisions those isometries every time i
have an isometry
there is a consequence one is i will
always generate
a a field uh a two to
a uh antisymmetric field which is a
payoff so
associated with my internal isometry
will be
a payoff and that payoff i associate
with
the game theory payoff matrix so that's
observable
and if i have isometries in time
that's associated with a
if you like a payoff that is
that's related to time we normally see
that payoff as
a um uh
associated with something like a
coriolis force okay and
and a gravitational field so there are
it's a different way of looking at
gravity um associated with these
symmetries
the isometries of the situation so
from that perspective i wouldn't
start with an assumption about the
compression
but i would point out that by making no
assumption about the compression
i generate compression uh based upon
things which i think i do know about
which is
by boundary conditions on flows my
understanding of isometries
my understanding of the stresses that
might occur
and so maybe the my position is
i don't want to start off with an
assumption about depression because i
don't have a sense about that
but i can back into it based upon my
understanding
of the other stresses of the problem
in my the boundary conditions i do know
about
and again hopefully that answers your
question
okay i'm not seeing any other questions
so uh just remains to thank everyone for
coming and thank you professor thomas
for a very interesting talk
well thank you and thank you everybody
let me thank everybody for your
your kind attention and hopefully i'll
i'll see some of you during the
conference and we can continue the the
conversation
thank you